Tom Waits’ raspy, almost growl-like singing
voice has become synonymous with the singer
and has been variously described by critics
as sounding like it was “soaked in whiskey”
or alternatively like it was “hit by a car”.
This distinctly recognisable sound combined
with Waits’ vast back catalogue of hits
has seen the artist approached numerous times
over the years by various advertising agencies,
all of whom he has rapidly rebuffed.
When once asked about why he had reservations
about his music being used for product promotion,
Waits very matter-of-factly summed up his
position: “Commercials are an unnatural
use of my work…
It’s like having a cow’s udder sewn to
the side of my face.
Painful and humiliating.”
Or even more bluntly,
I get it all the time, and they offer… a
whole lot of money.
Unfortunately I don’t want to get on the
bandwagon.
You know, when a guy is singing to me about
toilet paper – you may need the money but,
I mean, rob a 7-11!
Do something with dignity and save us all
the trouble of peeing on your grave.
That said, while Waits has never given permission
to have his music used in an advert, he did
once lend his voice to a commercial back in
1981 for dog food.
Waits eventually came to regret the ad and
once famously went on record as saying that
he’d rather have “a hot lead enema”
than “sell out” like that again.
Now you’d think that given his outspoken
and longstanding objections to having his
work used in a commercial sense that advertisers
would steer clear of the artist and perhaps
approach someone else when looking for a hit
to shill their product.
You’d, of course, be wrong.
Most famously, in 1988, Waits was approached
by the ad company Tracy-Locke on behalf of
Frito-Lay about using his hit, Step Right
Up, for a radio jinglepromoting Salsa Rio
Doritos.
Waits quickly declined the request, so the
company tried a different tack.
They hired a Tom Waits soundalike- someone
so good Frito-Lay’s own lawyers advised
the company that he sounded too much like
the real thing and the ad could cause legal
problems because of it.
However, after hearing a version of the ad
with a generic blues singer and deeming it
inferior to the Tom Waits soundalike version,
the executives at Frito-Lay decided to go
ahead with it anyway.
According to Waits, he had no idea that Frito-Lay
had done this until he was sitting in an LA
radio station chatting about his latest album
and the DJ played the commercial during the
ad break.
Waits later noted that the impersonation of
his voice was so eerily accurate that he began
to question whether or not he was actually
listening to himself.
It was only after placing a few phone calls
and confirming that the voice he’d heard
wasn’t him that Waits mood changed from
worriedly perplexed to enraged.
He stated,
Part of my character and personality and image
that I have cultivated is that I do not endorse
products…
…whoever was going to hear this and obviously
identify the voice would also identify that
Tom Waits in fact had agreed to do a commercial
for Doritos…
It embarrassed me.
I had to call all my friends, that if they
hear this thing, please be informed this is
not me.
I was on the phone for days.
I also had people calling me saying, “Gee,
Tom, I heard the new Doritos ad…”
Waits immediately filed suit which brought
about an unusual legal quandary.
You see, Waits didn’t own the rights to
the song Step Right Up; his former label did.
And, as it turned out, Frito-Lay had legally
obtained permission to use a version of the
song in their ad.
So what did Waits sue them for?
A few months before this singer Bette Midler
had won a case against Ford for an unauthorised
use of her likeness and voice.
Similar to Waits’ case, Ford hired a Midler
impersonator and soundalike (Midler’s long-time
backup singer Ula Hedwig) to sing one of her
songs in an ad after Midler, like Waits, told
them she wasn’t interested in doing the
ad.
The court initially ruled against Midler,
but upon appeal reversed their stance, noting
A voice is as distinctive and personal as
a face.
The human voice is one of the most palpable
ways identity is manifested… when a distinctive
voice of a professional singer is widely known
and is deliberately imitated in order to sell
a product, the sellers have appropriated what
is not theirs…
Following Midler’s lead, Waits sued on the
same grounds.
Curiously, Frito-Lay and the advertising agency
they contracted with were both aware of the
Midler case when they hired the soundalike,
but their legal team reasoned that Waits wasn’t
as well-known as Midler and you can’t legally
protect a style of singing or music; so while
there was a high risk they’d get sued, the
ad agency’s legal team felt it was unlikely
Waits would win and recommended Frito-Lay
go with the Waits’ knock-off version of
the commercial.
Ultimately when sued, this reasoning became
the basis of Frito-Lay’s entire defense,
with their lawyers arguing that: “A singer
is not widely known if he is only recognized
by his own fans, or fans of a particular sort
of music, or a small segment of the population”.
The judge presiding over the case disagreed,
noting that although Waits wasn’t as well
known as Midler, he was an internationally
famous artist who’d sold millions of records
and was known by many explicitly for his voice,
which was officially described in the court
case as:
Like how you’d sound if you drank a quart
of bourbon, smoked a pack of cigarettes and
swallowed a pack of razor blades.
. . . Late at night.
After not sleeping for three days.
Frito-Lay’s lawyers then had the audacity
to argue that Waits’ voice was that recognisable-
you know, even though Frito-Lay had gone to
the effort of hiring a guy who sounded exactly
like him for the express purpose of making
it seem like it was Waits singing in the ad.
The ruling ultimately went in Waits’ favor,
cementing the earlier Midler ruling that celebrities
and people who are well known in a relative
sense own the rights to all aspects of their
appearance and persona, including their voice,
provided it’s distinct enough.
Frito-Lay were then forced to pay Waits damages
of a whopping $2.6 million (a little over
$4 million today).
As for what he did with the money, Waits later
jokingly quipped, “Two and a half million
bucks?
Spent it all on candy.
My mom told me I was foolish.
I’ve always been foolish when it comes to
money…”
This case, combined with Waits’ earlier
comments about preferring to have hot lead
piped into his rear end than have his music
used in advertisement should have scared off
ad agencies forever, but amazingly the singer
has had to sue other companies like Levi’s,
Audi and the car manufacturer Opel for the
more or less the same type of thing Frito-Lay
did.
For instance, in the case of Levi’s, they
tried to skirt around Waits refusal to lend
his music to ads by licensing a cover of one
of his songs that had previously been licensed
to the artist in question by Waits.
Waits wasn’t amused and ultimately the company
were forced to issue a full page apology in
an issue of Billboard magazine.
In the case of Opel, they used a Waits’
soundalike after failing to get Waits to agree
to a deal and, unsurprisingly, lost the case,
this time with Waits donating the money he
won from the lawsuit to charity.
More recently, Waits has become embroiled
in a legal battle with an award winning French
circus show directed by Bartabas the Furious
which uses 16 of Waits songs for their performances.
Representatives of the show claim they paid
the necessary €400,000 royalties to Waits’
agent for use of the songs.
Waits denies that he or his agent ever cleared
the songs for use in the show, and once again
articulates his objections to such a thing:
These songs were not found like driftwood
on the beach: they came from good families.
I turn down all commercial product endorsement
offers and rarely collaborate or lend my name
or work to other endeavors.
… That value has been taken and exploited
for the profit and promotion of Bartabas’s
career and for his religious and political
ideology, which neither the songs nor I chose
to express.
Ironically, Tom Waits is often mistaken for
the actor Ron Perlman who shares a similar,
distinctive growly voice and haggard look
to such an extent Waits’ own fan club redirects
Perlman fans to his IMDB page.